Thank you to Curiosity Stream for supporting
PBS Digital Studios!
1,2,3, go!
Don’t rush me!
Philip, I promise I’ll catch you.
I know, but how do I know?
I’m your wife.
Don’t you trust me?
Of course!
Then go for it!
Okay, okay!
Here we go…
Ah, I can’t!
Oh, forget it.
No, no. I can do this.
1...2...3…
Aaaah!
Trust is hard.
Counting on something you can’t see or touch
to be there for you when you need it can be
scary.
But whether we like it or not, you and everyone
you know plays a global game of trust every
day.
It’s called MONEY.
Money is imaginary.
This bill can’t be used as food or clothing
or shelter.
And yet it has value because we’ve all agreed
to pretend that it does.
The employee who accepts a paycheck for their
hours of work, the shopper who puts a new
pair of shoes on their credit card--even the
bankrobber risking his life for a bagful of
benjamins--they’re all putting their faith
in a collective fantasy that only works because
everyone else believes in it too.
The earliest types of currency were things
that had practical value, like food or livestock
or furs.
These commodity monies didn’t require much
trust.
A toolmaker is willing to accept a bag of
barley as payment, because even if he has
more than he needs, he can be pretty sure
that someone else will want it.
Because, you know, you can eat it!
But commodity money isn’t very convenient.
Try schlepping forty bags of barley across
town just to pay your rent.
And if your landlord doesn’t spend it right
away, it could mold or get eaten by rats.
And if he wants to buy a tool from you, he
has to carry the sacks all the way back to
your house.
At some point, someone realized that life
would be so much easier if instead of actually
carrying sacks of barley back and forth, we
could just agree to pretend to carry sacks
of barley back and forth.
We’d just need some way to keep track of
it all.
This 5,000 year old Sumerian clay tablet is
one of the oldest examples of writing ever
found.
It says: “29,086 measures of barley, 37
months.”
Writing wasn’t invented for royal decrees
or epic poems... it was invented to keep track
of imaginary sacks of barley--in other words,
credits and debits.
So when St. Paul wrote that “love of money
is the root of all evil,” he may have had
a point, but he couldn’t have written it
down it if it weren’t for money.
Once humans were willing to think about value
symbolically, it wasn’t long before we started
using other materials as currency.
But of all the elements on the periodic scale,
which one should we use?
Well, first, it should be a solid.
And it can’t be toxic, obviously.
It can’t be reactive.
Or radioactive.
It should be easy to extract and smelt.
Rare enough to be valuable, but common enough
to be practical.
It shouldn’t corrode, rust or degrade.
But it should be soft enough to cut and shape.
And… it should be pretty.
That really only leaves a few good options,
and the best fit is GOLD.
We’re used to thinking of gold as inherently
precious, but the main reason we use it as
a currency is… because it’s great at being
a currency.
Physically, it’s not much more useful than
a paper bill.
Maybe less.
At least you can burn paper for warmth.
So that paranoid survivalist burying bullion
in his backyard is still playing the trust
game.
He’s trusting that even after the apocalypse,
everyone will agree to pretend that his gold
is valuable.
The next big financial innovation came around
640 BCE in what is now Turkey, when someone
had the bright idea to pre-weigh lumps of
gold and stamp them with the royal seal, and
KA-CHING! the first coins were born.
That stamp is the king’s personal guarantee
of the coin’s worth.
No need to weigh it or test its purity--if
you trust the king, you can trust this coin.
Counterfeiting is essentially royal impersonation--a
serious offense--and still known today as
a lese-majeste crime.
Hm.
Maybe that’s why the organization that investigates
counterfeiting in America is the same one
that protects the president from attacks:
the Secret Service.
Coins were so convenient that they quickly
spread all over the world, and almost every
incarnation had some sort of symbol of trusted
authority on it.
If you were lucky
enough to have a lot of these coins, you’d
need somewhere safe to store them, so BANKS
were founded where you could exchange your
gold coins for a slip of paper called a “promissory
note”: a “promise” that the bearer could
come back for their coins whenever they wanted.
But a funny thing happened: these notes were
so light and convenient that people actually
preferred them as currency, and VOILA: Paper
money.
Governments eventually took over the role
of printing banknotes, and covered them with
all types of assurances that this is more
than just a flat rectangle of cotton and linen.
We especially love to put images of famous
people on our bills--not just to honor the
people, but to use their stature and respect
to reinforce trust in the currency.
I mean, look at ol’ George there.
Doesn’t he seem so TRUSTWORTHY?
“This money is REAL.
I cannot tell a lie.”
So when you deposit your paycheck in the bank,
you’re taking it on faith that you’ll
be able to withdraw it later as cash, which
is a promise that can be redeemed for gold,
which you’re hoping other people will exchange
for food and shelter and all the other stuff
we need to live.
Wow, that’s some Inception levels of trust
going on there.
Kinda scary when you think about it.
Sure, but the fact that money is imaginary
does give you a lot more power in your relationship
with it.
How you think about money affects its very
nature.
In a future episode, we’ll look at how this
global trust experiment has moved beyond the
physical realm into the invisible world of
cyberspace.
How can trust possibly survive when the majority
of the world’s wealth exists only in the
minds of computers?
We trust you’ll keep watching.
Thank you to Curiosity Stream for supporting PBS Digital Studios.
Curiosity Stream is a subscription streaming service that offers documentaries
and non-fiction title from a variety of film-makers. Including Curiosity Stream Originals!
For example, you can watch "The Ascent of Money" to learn more about the history of finance.
You can learn more at curiositystream.com/twocents